we're going to begin this hour with our
series that we call a more perfect union
which aims to show that what unites us
As Americans is actually far greater
than what divides us you may be
surprised we actually have a lot in
common an estimated 41 percent of
military veterans live with mental
health issues from depression and
anxiety to sleep disorders in PTSD
Marine veteran Jessica Rambo what a name
I like that it's on a mission it's
perfect glad you're right it's on a
mission to help them heal as Meg Oliver
shows us she's traveled the country on a
bus for several years and use art
therapy to help vets struggling with
their mental health the 36 year old
woman sees it as a new way to serve her
country
oh good girl come on these days you can
find retired marine and Mom Jessica
Rambo living in the woods just outside
Atlanta sometimes I can't believe how
far I've come it's her first home with
roots a place she intends to be both a
refuge and an art studio for veterans
struggling with their mental health when
you leave the service there's no
transition there's no detox there's no
how do I become a normal human being
again and it's extremely difficult to
get a veteran to open up through ART she
says veterans can find a way to release
and heal what is it about art therapy
that helps them I think it's just being
able to create something or tell a story
without communication they can be alone
in their safe place and it's just
another tool in a toolbox I call it
creating your own Mental Health Care
Package born into a big military family
Jessica always had two loves her artwork
and the arm forces did your mom
encourage you to join the military
absolutely not
I was an artist I was creative but I
knew I wanted to do something bigger and
greater than myself in 2006 she enlisted
with the Marines and traveled the world
as a combat camera person but only four
years into her dream job Jessica was in
a car accident that forced her to retire
early she suffered a traumatic brain
injury internal damage and became
addicted to alcohol and painkillers I
had a failed marriage my relationship
with my children really was affected and
so I knew that if I was going to save
that relationship I had to end all
be-all and one of my children had said
something that really affected me really
hit the the route that I needed it to
hit and that was it what did they say
every morning he was missing breakfast
and he said Mom can I please go to
school tomorrow
I'm hungry I have to wait till lunch and
that was unacceptable to me it breaks my
heart yeah mine too just free living
how that was back then all the things
that keep dripping you up the Jessica
got sober and rediscovered her other
passion she enrolled in art school which
helped her overcome her own struggles
with depression and anxiety that really
gave me A New Path a new way to serve my
community that path was the paint can
project a mission to bring ammo cans
filled with art supplies to vets across
the country with the logos for me she
bought an old school bus named it the
painted Buffalo and hit the road thank
you sir why did you call it the painted
buffalo bison have been used and abused
through United States history and then
kind of discarded and the veteran the
same way were used and abused for our
country and then some of us feel like
we're discarded I am Jess and I built
this schooly for my family and I the
road trip Journey started in 2019 with
her son Liam crisscrossing the country
they've hit 38 States and helped
hundreds of veterans battling mental
health issues
hoping to be able to get the veterans to
make some pinch pots on this day we rode
in the painted Buffalo to a nearby Art
event
the bus she now calls her old home after
four years on the road you're in the
living room
yep and where are you I'm in the captain
this chair at the American Legion pose
245 in Adairsville Georgia the room is
filled with veterans there for one
purpose trying our best to spread
veteran awareness and mental health
recovery and our way of doing that is
through making and telling stories the
impact seen almost immediately hard
sleeping yeah it's hard getting in a
regular rhythm Lamar Wilkie was in the
Army for three years in Vietnam the 75
year old says alcohol used to be his
coping mechanism for stress is this
helping yes you do keep your mind it
keeps your mind occupied creative
creative something Sean Allen struggles
with PTSD the 46 year old spent four
years in Iraq with the Marines he found
Jessica on Instagram and decided to take
a chance I feel like a plane in the mud
like a kid again yeah
free your mind a little bit yeah I mean
I'm kind of nervous just because I
I'm not used to meeting a whole bunch of
people and I don't really get out much
so
um now I'm doing all right though if
there's a veteran out there watching
this who may be struggling with their
mental health what do you want them to
know reach out you know I was very alone
and quiet about what I was dealing with
but as soon as I picked up the phone and
called one of my friends they were like
oh yeah me too and instantly I felt
better because I knew I wasn't alone and
that's all of us can do that whether
you're a veteran or not
so important to ask for help Jessica is
now holding workshops for vets in a new
studio on our property and continues to
have regular events outside Atlanta and
she is truly an inspiration look her up
on Instagram the painted Buffalo that's
how people reach out to her and they
find out about her next event I'm
telling you Meg we needed a story like
this morning because I so believe that
the most people are good in this world
and in this country and it's nice to be
reminded of people people like Jessica
her last name really is Rambo
that was great thank you Jessica Rambo
thank you it is terrible though for
veterans to feel as she said that they
are sometimes and abused I mean we ask
so much of them for them to come home
I'm struck by how some of these
individuals they look so different now
than what they did when they were in the
spring of their youth when they were
fighting for our country yeah and I
applaud Sean Allen for talking to us but
the good news is that the Department of
Veterans Affairs says 90 percent of
veterans have now reached out for mental
health services it's increased 90 so
it's pretty good that's important yeah
awesome thank you very much